Hey, everyone its Mark Weins with Migrationology.com Good morning from Manila
I had an amazing sleep last night and just woke up and had a quick breakfast
But the plan for the day
Is that Ying and I have been invited to eat at the spiral buffet here at The Sofitel
which is supposed to be one of the ultimate buffets in Manila
in the Philippines as well as in Asia and after having breakfast at sofitel yesterday
I can only imagine how amazing the lunch buffet is gonna be so that's the plan for the day, but for right now
I've got a lot of work to do. I'm gonna start video editing
Now this is a toy that I really love to have at home someday
Well that is some excellent espresso and now I'm gonna start some serious video editing
Give you a view of this hard rain out here
Before in the morning when I showed that view you can see all the skyline and the ocean over here and almost
It's almost completely invisible now
It's right at noon it is buffet time. We're walking down to the spiral buffet. I can't wait for this
So they have 21 dining ateliers
Which are kind of like different dining stations or food stations, and you can see there's hot japanese. There's wood fire pizza
oven there is
Picking duck all Sorts of amazing sounding
things to eat
Hello. Thank you
We arrived to the spiral Buffet and this is the most
Unbelievable display of food that I think I have ever seen in my entire life
I don't know if I've ever seen so much food in one
Place as this buffet. They literally have everything you can imagine from
Sushi to bread to an entire cheese room and an entire chocolate room to the Asian and Filipino section. There's Thai food there's
roast duck and chicken there's an Indian station, and so we just walked through every station, but have not started eating yet, and
It's it's just ridiculous ridiculous
And not to mention where we are seating king and I each have an entire like three person sofa to ourselves
and an entire table, which I
think they know that we're gonna accumulate a lot of plates at one time so we have like a
Like a six person table all to ourselves
They said this is their signature olive bread at spiral buffet and now I don't want to eat too much of this
But it does all that is hot and fresh
It's so crisp on the edges so crusty
I have absolutely no idea where to start so I'm just gonna start with the first thing in my path, and that is the Japanese
station
I decided to go straight in for some
Sashimi and some sushi, and then some oysters the oysters are flown in from France and
Pop open the head you Paul. You can eat oysters
Well, that's ridiculously good. Oh, it's just so smooth and silky soft and just
Disintegrates on my tongue oh Sashimi, and I actually forgot to get my Wasabi and and soy sauce
But I cannot wait I gotta go back for it later
Just so pure and so fresh
I'm not even sure how to eat caviar correctly
But I think I'll eat it with bread and I got some kind of green caviar in some kind of Black Caviar
Which I will put onto this little piece of bread
nice and salty
and very Seafoody tasting, but I love that like
Those little like bead. It tastes like you're eating little beads
This one is the crocodile
Okay
For my second plate I decided to go Filipino
It's normally of course this has to be eaten with rice and I like to eat it with rice but in order to save space
I just had to forego the rice that's a sacrifice. I'm having to make today. This is a dish
He said is stingray with coconut milk
Oh wow
It's so soft and tender
it tastes like shredded chicken and
then with that Chilli
That's wonderful. Oh that's so good and the other interesting thing. They have her is
Adobo, but this is not pork or chicken adobo. This is crocodile Adobo. Which is very attractive
Oh, I've had crocodile before that is very chewy and rubbery
Rubbery that is incredibly tender crocodile
very
like a kind of a cross between fish and meat and
That's awesome. Another thing they have in the filipino food section of the buffet is balloon. Which is the famous?
Fertilized egg, I can't remember if I should open it from this side, or this side
But I know there's there's soup inside of it. There's juice inside of it. So you want to crack it and
Try to break off the top
Oh, no, I think I got the dry side okay. I think I made a mistake. I think I'll go the other side
There's a little bit of soup in there
Oh, that's like. That's like chicken juice running down my chicken soup. Oh, that's chicken juice
Do you run running down my can that just tastes like chicken soup though?
We can see that the embryo there and all those feathers
There we go. I'm gonna dip this guy in vinegar and
then
Dip it in a little bit of salt?
And then I think I can one bite the whole thing
Hmm. It's kind of just like a hard-boiled egg
But with a lot more textures going on another thing is that it does kind of have a stronger like eggy flavor
So if you've thought of it
If you haven't if you think about it the flavor of a hard-boiled egg and just kind of magnify that flavor times a couple times
You'll have that and add some more textures to it like feathers you have a balloon
but yeah, I think it's really not as bad as many people say it is I
I enjoyed that and I think it's makes a fantastic protein snack
For my next course I went to the Indian station and they have just a full selection of Indian food
I got one piece of naan and then one of my favorite forms of Dal
Which is dal Makhani and then got some prawns some butter chicken
Some paneer, and then I threw on a piece of prime rib there just for good measure
into the Naan
so creamy and
Dal Makhani is superb and I think this one is buttered chicken if I remember correctly
I am taking a little time out after that plate of Indian food to post a photo of the oyster on Instagram
That should be good
next course, I think I'm going in for a little bit of European station and
Got some a bunch of things cooked in butter and cream which look amazing and these are mushrooms and mashed potatoes
Oh, I love mushrooms and those I think they're just sauteed in butter and thyme
Okay, then. I had to get some mussels. Which I think are oh
Once lit up. I think these are just cooked in cream and butter as well two muscles in one shell
That is extremely rich, but that's that does taste good there might be there might be cheese in there as well. I'm not sure
I really wish I was 22 years old again
I cannot eat as much as I used to I'm really starting to get full, but I think I'm Gonna go
To the Japanese hot station and get some Japanese hot dishes
But I might take a five-minute breather right here on this couch
I got some Japanese Sukiyaki in the bowl, and then I got some Kimchi
One more oysters for good measure and some sashimi
That is nice and salty and just a little bit sweet and chaste that with some Kimchi
I love compute. We just received word of the final call for the buffet because it closes at 3:00 p.m.
So we managed to eat here for almost three hours, and I enjoyed every minute of it
but I'm very impressed with the buffet just an Incredible quantity and
Diversity of things available and what I like is that a lot of the food
You know while some buffets the food sits there for a long time and starts to not taste so good here they really
Put an emphasis on Fresh food. So you'll see them cooking in small portions, and then adding it to the
serving pans
Which is really nice eating at the spiral buffet was included in our stay at the sofitel which was sponsored?
Because we spoke at the event yesterday
But I want to say a big thank you for to spiral buffet for having us here
And that was delicious
and this is by all means the most impressive and diverse and
Grandest buffet that I have ever eaten at in my life. I'm gonna end the video for today here
Because I'm about to go take a nap for the rest of the day. Maybe oh, yeah another thing
I think it might be worth it to have a room at so if you tell when you eat at this buffet because
If I had to drive somewhere now, I like to go home. I don't actually think I could do it
But nice to have a room here. Yeah, I'm gonna end the video here, and I want to say a big
Thank you for watching this video
Please remember to give it a thumbs up leave a comment below and I will see you tomorrow for the next video